a lot of people watching this channel
might want to have a career in computing
and you work in industry so I thought
kind of we could just maybe have a chat
about what it's like from your point of
view what you're looking for from people
and what you know what people should be
thinking about when the you know what a
period is thank you that's a great
question I mean I hire about ten people
a year a lot of them go into what I
would call a Jason sees to computing so
for example I've got a team that's
working on sensing in the life sciences
and the big data is hitting everything
right so if you're a data scientist
which most computer scientists have some
inclination towards at these days and it
is a huge premium you will have those
kinds of fields as well open to you just
so people know right you know the
organization you are at for us I'll try
to be concise but I'm in HP Labs and I'm
in the position where I direct a large
group of people around the world in
everything from mechatronics and
robotics to 3d printing software to what
we call security printing the security
printing also ties in a lot to the
Internet of Things if you use that
cliche being able to interrogate a
physical object whether it's a label
packaging 3d printed object manufactured
object and then be able to get useful
information to yourself off of that and
so the software folks that I'm looking
for involved in everything from
analytics big data to algorithms being
able to add to the sort of signal and
image processing that I believe it -
with sensing so a broad set of skills in
there we do also need people can roll up
the sleeves and make this stuff leggy
right so because it's really nice to
talk about these algorithms but I've got
to put them on a mobile phone in the end
and so I do need people who are good
with you know everything from xamarin to
you know the follows on to droid and iOS
programming pretty much everything right
now has a processor somehow involved in
it and the ability for you to code at
the level below just the UI you know the
UI based software is going to help you
in terms of hiring what we're looking
for obviously our people who have a very
can-do attitude who have experience
across both web technology and non web
technology right it's better not to edge
and halt yourself and just focus on
algorithms or just focus on web
generally speaking because I'm in a
research
lab we will tend to hire people who are
better at the algorithm side and at
writing those types of things but we do
have webby type things as well because
any technology now is going to go live
it's going to go mobile it's going to go
on the cloud and so we're looking for
people who have had experience along the
lines of what I saw here last year when
I went through with the I think it was a
third-year competition and with the
third-year competition you saw a lot of
students kind of rolling up the sleeves
bringing different technologies to bear
and saying oh yeah we need a webby
aspect to that because that's going to
make it
demonstrable at the fair but it also has
to do something useful and so I think
you see this real combination people
always talk about you know older coders
like myself who grew up writing you know
ones and zeros literally at the start to
folks now who know how to exercise an
API for the web people people on the
website say boy I wish those old guys
would just do something interesting and
the old guys say I wish those young guys
would just do something that meant
something right but it's actually
there's a real good commonality between
there and I think what we're seeing is
that because so much technology now is
intimately tied to needing good software
to be written for it you really need
both of those and so people who have
that ability to you know do something
with raspberry Pi or Arduino something
where you're kind of really getting your
hands dirty and looking at sort of the
older style programming languages
whether it's C C++ even Java to people
who are much more webby you know
building out websites using Jason or
something else if they'll people have
both of those things or even Python I
really like Python because I think it
gets people's hands dirty but at the
same time they're able to percolate up
from that so that's what we're looking
for and of course being in research if
you're good at R if you're good at
MATLAB if you go to some of the open
source types of approaches we're looking
for that as well those are just a
starting point though so what we're
really looking for and particularly in a
research lab is we're looking for
character right so I I get to be pulled
in I've got much more technical people
in the various areas on my team of
course than I am but we pull people in
and I try to ask them off-the-cuff
questions to see how to handle them so
one guy and it was surprising I said
what's the worst thing you ever did that
you didn't report you know to EH&S so
environmental health and safety and I
didn't expect an answer but he actually
gave me one and so yeah we had this
radiation leak and covered it up and got
all the material put away and all that
and I'm like wow this is kind of
disturbing but the way he handled it he
said it wasn't the big deal and it would
have shut down the lab and it was you
know so it was tritium or something that
was actually relatively easy to clean up
in the end we ended up offering the guy
a job and hiring him but if this is
astonishing admission and so I'm looking
for people like that because even though
the story could have been potentially
embarrassing him at first I was like do
I have to call the HMS it was he had
hindsight the guy was very honest with
me and he told me what he did and why he
did it and that he took responsibility
for cleaning up the situation and not
getting the lab closed down for a year
so you have to kind of learn
off-the-cuff questions really help
asking people that kind of shakes them
out and you find out a lot that way if
you get somebody kind of off the normal
mark for things they'll end up telling
you something they've done that was very
fascinating that won't show up on the
resume because they might have been
embarrassed about it and so that's one
of the things that I definitely look for
in a software person somebody who's done
something that had nothing to do with
their classes and they did it because of
their love for what software can do as
we all recognize that now we're going
we're in a real transition right now in
the world we're going from a world where
open-source software has become de
rigueur and people know how to go out
and get software that can do certain
tasks we know which type of software we
can actually use we've watched the you
know the evolution from Hadoop to spark
etcetera things change over time but
it's more and more open source for the
sort of pedestrian things that we need
to do to exist in a cloud-based mobile
world that's about to happen to hardware
and so you look at Nottingham University
of Nottingham here there's some
fascinating work being done and added of
manufacturing and new forms of
manufacturing I have teams that work on
that the majority of the people that are
on my teams working in 3d printing are
software people and it's because 3d
printing if you're doing additive
manufacturing and you're looking at
merging masks customized with mass
production parts so all the mass
production parts are the same
somebody's parts merge onto that in the
end you know it's that's easy enough to
do we're just going to snap those parts
together like a Lego set not that easy
how do you actually produce those parts
how do you track them how do you
validate them how do you forensically
analyze them all of that takes very
strong algorithmic expertise it takes
somebody who can actually put together
the software in a modular fashion and
somebody who's smart enough to figure
out I need to go look at what a
manufacturing line looks like and see
what they're they're addressing and so
for me I see a lot of this going on
where people say yeah 3d printing it's
going to replace manufacturing no it's
not going to replace manufacturing it's
going to augment it if you look at what
manufacturing is now people have the
largest capital assets most companies
have if their manufacturing company is
what they have in a manufacturing line
they've got robotics they've got you
know very fast production line that
assume the same product is going through
multiple times it's the old assembly
line mentality and so everything has
been streamlined optimized overproduced
so that I can get as many parts through
here as possible because I make more
money if I do that now goes away and you
say well what do I do with you know
let's say I've got a 30 year capital
asset that I'm losing money off of if I
get rid of it in the next you know 10 20
30 years so that's a big part of what's
going on is how we can merge what we're
doing with additive manufacturing with
existing manufacturing lines it's not
going to happen with hand-waving it's
going to happen with software and so
that's a good example people who've
actually addressed that that's one
specific area look at healthcare for
another one if we want to draw in other
areas so I've got teams working on what
are called surface enhanced Raman
spectroscopy sensors and what that
basically is is these tiny little nano
fingers that when they collapse on an
analyte there's an enhancing effect by
the materials that we use gold tips etc
and very small you know just a few
hundred nanometers in length for these
fingers when an analyte or a Simpson
single chemical gets trapped inside of
here I hit it with a laser light and the
Raman scattering that I get off of that
is enhanced up to 10 to the 12 times so
up to a million million times
enhancement
of the signal that I would normally get
off of that analyte because of the
architecture I put around that as we
start looking at that and you can see
imagine the future I've got some kind of
a smart rag or a smart plastic surface
that I just take rub across this table
take it out and sense everything that
was on the table right so it's going to
make forensic analysis extremely fast
and as you can see down the road that
might include things like polymerase
chain reaction or PCR which means that I
can get automatic DNA sequencing or RNA
sequencing off of what I picked up if
it's proteinaceous so there's a lot of
different things that I can do with that
technology all of that is software
bioinformatics is what makes me be able
to analyze the DNA in the RNA all the
normal signal processing that I would
normally do for audio you know so you're
an audio expert you know about that
you've got one key signal processing
that's going on I've got imaging which
is 2d signal processing that comes on
there so I'm looking for those types of
things when I bring in a candidate for
hire and I'm looking for somebody who's
got of strength in one area and then
breadth across the area and so people
talk about this this is I'm pologize
again to the non States people this is
States jargon we look for a t-shaped
software engineer which means somebody
who's got a lot of breadth in this
direction and can go deep in one area
for research I'm looking for a comb
shaped person so once somebody has got
that breadth but they can go deep in
several areas now they'll be typically
from my lab they'll be a master or PhD
so we know they go deep in one area
because they had to get that
dissertation approved and they've got
smart people like the professors here
nodding him walking them through that
but I'm looking for somebody who also
took it and went deep in another area so
for example somebody may be very
interested in electrical engineering and
because of their thesis they had to do
one thing let's say working on you know
the sayers that I talked about the
surface enhanced Raman spectroscopy but
because they were interested in signal
processing they spent the rest of their
time doing music and so they figured out
how to build you know analog and digital
circuits to do electronic music or
something like that if I see something
like that then I know this person really
is interested in that they're not just
doing it because it was a convenient
path to a degree or a degree that they
thought they'd have a you know
livelihood in
and so we're really looking for that and
I try to throw students not you know
with that
that being said I'm one person and the
other people on my interview team are
going to be looking for those specific
skills to make sure that they can't
sneak away with that and so for me I
will typically cover the few areas that
I'm qualified to look at perhaps imaging
perhaps or statistics or analytics but
other people on my team will be taking
them very deep into what's under the
hood in terms of a cloud deployment they
said they did right or what's under the
hood for some type of an intelligent
system that they supposedly designed and
in most cases you'll find out the
student will admit very quickly oh I
actually relied on Bob or Susie or
whoever to actually do some of that work
and they think that's they're afraid to
bring that up in an interview as far as
interviews go that's that's when we know
we've hit goal right because we want
people who can admit they need somebody
else to get a big project on if it's
somebody who actually did the whole
project by themselves hmm might not be
that good of a project right but if it's
something where they worked with a bunch
of other smart people and that's what
I've been lucky at in life I've worked
always with a lot of people smarter than
me and the project that I'm working with
you dig into the expertise they have in
you're like wow thank you now I don't
have to sweat the details I need to
understand what you did but I don't have
to do the details and so we're looking
for people who can admit they've
actually worked with people and at least
an area of their project who are better
than them and you're going to have to do
that in life we all know that and the
farther you go in this field the smarter
the people around you are you know
unless you're unfortunate that's if
you're fortunate and so you learn to tap
into those people and make a bigger
project counter that so you look at
anything that's big you want to get into
industry you've got to be on a big
project that you've worked with a lot of
other intelligent people on you can
acknowledge them very well and you can
understand what they did without having
to be an expert in that and so again
it's that comme chez person you've got
to know how to fill in those voids that
you don't go deep in if you can do that
you're going to interview quite well at
least for a research done you mentioned
about excelling in questions to catch
people not necessarily all but just just
to see what makes them tick and it was
the way they might mess that up I mean
I'm assuming you want them to tell the
truth of these you know you know not
looking for big cover-ups and stuff so
yeah that's a great question and it is
hard for somebody to hide and I think
that's why people are honest when you
give them the you know kind of
off-the-cuff question if some of them
off-guard I'm looking for character and
so one of the things you can definitely
do to blow an interview is show that you
don't have character and so if I ask a
question like that and I say what's the
worst thing that ever happened and it
becomes kind of a humblebrag
where the person's like oh the worst
thing I ever did was I didn't catch that
my colleague was cheating fast enough
that's not a good answer right so so I'm
not looking for those kind of humble
bags as I'm the one I mentioned before
where a colleague had an incident and he
cleaned it up and took responsibility
for its cleanup was shocking at first
but then I realized he had character
because he knew how to follow through on
that and so if somebody says oh well the
worst thing that ever happened to me was
something my colleague did or something
this person did or the project failed
because the people I was working with in
follow through on it may well be true
that's probably not something you want
to bring up in an interview in an
interview you really want to focus on
the way you handled adversity and
brought that to a decent conclusion and
we all run into adversity and by the way
when some of the interviews and they
tell me they work with a jerk they're
usually telling the truth that's a tough
one and so if you see that they really
were working with a jerk you try to see
if they can find a way to steer that
into a positive because we have to do
that we all work with jerks and life we
might even be jerks occasionally and you
know we don't mean to be but we are and
so the way in which somebody is going to
work with us when we are having a bad
day like that or the way in which we
work with somebody when they're clearly
having an off day or life time is is
really important and so we want to do is
see that that person can actually handle
that and move forward positively so if I
don't see that in response to a question
like that that's one way of blowing it
another way of blowing an interview
would be for somebody to just be
focusing on what I would call the
quantitative aspects of what they've
done they're really focused on the
number of things they've done number of
publications number of you know grants
that they've got number of awards
they've won those types of things those
are important but if the person doesn't
then go a level deeper and tell me what
it was that they did to get those awards
or what they felt the award was about or
who else should have shared in that
award that's another way to kind of blow
an interview because you're going to be
working with a team you're
be working with a bunch of people if
we've done our jobs right hiring they're
going to be just as smart as you or on
average right in the meet in the mean
and so it's a weird thing but if you're
actually in an interview and you're
spending too much time talking about
yourself and not the people around you
you're actually insulting the person
interviewing you
you're not insulting the people you work
with and this is a tricky one to
describe but I think if you stick with
me here you'll get it if you're acting
like the interviewer like you're the
best thing that's ever happened to their
company you may well be right you might
be the best in that area but you're also
insulting them because you're implying
the people they've already got working
there or even the interviewer themselves
because again you'll have technical
interviewers are not as good as you so
it's a it's a tricky one the balance you
do want to come across positive you want
to show that you have that talent but
you don't want to insult the person
interviewing you or insult worse yet the
team that you haven't met and so I think
that's a tricky one there you have to
it's a delicate balance between humility
proper humility and also being very self
confident and so I'm looking for
somebody who can be self confident but
not have to do it at the expense of
others and so one of the ways of doing
that in an interview is obviously
looking for ways to positively
contribute so if somebody tells me
they've got a talent for this they're
like well the reason why I did that was
my grandma needed something that would
helped her stand up and I realized that
grandma did not have really good leg
muscles anymore and so what I had to do
was going to be something that actually
augmented her since some people could
physically move around where somebody
else said my grandma still have stolen
muscles but she has problem with her
motor you know her motor neurons and so
if I was able to stimulate those I could
do that so it's an example from you know
bionics or bio you know some type of bio
assist that would be a good example of
it somebody who said oh yeah and by the
way I got an award for that but that
wasn't the reason I went into it right
and so those are the types of things so
if you've got applications for what
you've done
that's a far better way to talk about it
then in terms of the recognition you got
from society whether you won a
scholarship or you won an award
yes we look at those yes those matter
but they don't matter as much in an
interview we're looking at that that's
what got you to the interview
and so that's an important point to make
when we do interviews they will depend
on the location if we do an interview
for example in the Bay Area and San
Francisco Bay Area in the States will
have a thousand candidates for a
position and so if we're interviewing
you you're already one in 100 or one and
two hundred or one and four hundred
whatever it ends up being because of the
number we hire in we're pretty confident
you've got a good resume right and so
the interview really goes beyond that
resume or you wouldn't be there even in
Colorado which is the state I live in if
we put out a position that has any
interest to the software community we'll
have a hundred to 200 applicants and
these are top people I mean we get
applicants who are like oh I finished
first in China this year on this
particular software challenge like China
that's there's a few people in that
country I think a lot of people come
into an interview and one of the reasons
they fail some of what I was talking
about before the humblebrag the giving
proper attribution realigning what they
were doing with an application is they
forgot that we've already looked at
hundreds of resumes and we already like
you right so we're looking for something
in the interview that wasn't in the
resume so it's not just here's my resume
job done you meet me and then you know
whether aside you basically said I
resumes kind of like the headlines
exactly now let's find out what this guy
oh this girl is like yeah that's a great
point and the thing to keep in mind is
now you're competing against the best of
the best of the best right so we've gone
through those thousand resumes those
thousand resumes presumably were
qualified people from a much larger pool
and now we're interviewing three or four
of you for the final job if somebody's
not local to you how do you approach
that if you have applicants
internationally or is it that they need
to get to you or have that work just out
in chess because we have also got a
global audience here so absolutely well
we do try to do a three-stage screening
and so we'll go through all the resumes
and of course we want people from all
over the world there's you know there's
brilliance everywhere we'll do a phone
screen to find out you know who the best
of the best are and that will prevent
them from having to travel or anything
else
some people are allowed to be
distributed remotely so I have a person
Indiana of a person in
in Seattle and a person in Chennai India
you know then so these these are really
good folks we've decided they can be
there because they can successfully work
from you know from the remote spot most
people will come into the Bay Area or
Bristol Bristol UK here or Fort Collins
Colorado and work and so will typically
do is if they've got past in the phone
screening they got on to stage three
which is the last stage before hire we
will pay for them to fly out to where
we're going to do the interview
typically the Bay Area because that's
where the bulk of our research effort is
but it'll also be Bristol UK or four
columns depending on where we're going
to bring them in to hire and so we will
hire internationally but tend to ask
them to relocate to one of our global
offices and so it's really up to the
person do they want to make that move
from let's say Malaysia to a let's say a
China office in Shanghai do they want to
make the move from we get some brilliant
person who's let's say from Egypt we
don't have a research operation there
are they willing to move from Egypt to
say Bristol UK so that's up to the
person but we do we do definitely
encourage people from all over the world
to come in because it's it's good for us
I mean a big part of what I've worked on
the last three or four years in the
quantitative standpoint for data
analytics is looking at the impact of
diversity on creativity and it's huge so
we know that I mean we know that the
more diverse type of employee that we
bring in the better overall products
we're going to get
is much more powerful than for example
two craters which were the
state-of-the-art when I did my master's
thesis because I was working on
impedance tomography back then and I was
killing the Craig computer I had to
actually chase students out with add
music at 3 in the morning so I could add
two Cray to myself nowadays you do that
I've got more power on my iPhone than I
ever had with your credit computer